[Music]
all right as we reported
california governor gavin newsom's
latest stay-at-home order is officially
in effect and is sparking fury among
golden state residents
orange county sheriff don barnes is
insisting his deputies
will not enforce this shutdown deeming
it a matter of personal responsibility
not law enforcement and now not law
enforcement saying his
actions are in line with the
constitution that sheriff don barnes
joins us now sheriff
what brought you to this conclusion
well there's so many factors that go
into it but it's been a it's been a long
year for everybody we know that
it's been very impactful upon all the
businesses and residents of orange
county in california
but i just don't think that it's
something that falls in line with a law
enforcement priority
we have many other responsibilities that
we're dealing with
many responsibilities really aren't ours
that we're dealing with homelessness
mental illness substance use disorder
delay lay on this one more additional
expectation i think is not only fair or
unfair to law enforcement to the
residents of orange county but it's just
unfair
overall i don't think it stands the
constitutional test
listen sheriff i i don't know how it's
like out in your county
but when i walk into a restaurant
locally i see plexiglass
i see distancing i seen tables separated
i see
voluntary less capacity these were these
owners want to comply
are you noticing the same thing we are
noticing
exactly that every one of the businesses
that are operating have met the
expectations of the state
the state has come out and has said if
you need to
if you want to continue operating as a
business you have to do these things and
the
it's like the goal posts keep moving 10
yards back week by week
and i don't know how you can decide
which businesses are essential which
businesses
aren't what uh food restaurant can be
open which one cannot
i heard the story that you mentioned
earlier about in los angeles where
yeah a lady had a tent she'd been
operating and riding her parking lot as
a tent for several hundred people that
they get to operate she cannot
i don't know how you can have such
disparate rules and expect people to
want to follow them
when the comp when they uh when they if
they follow those they're in essence
putting themselves out of business
sure likelihood is gone what bothers me
most about people in your possession
in your profession is that you're going
through enough this whole push that
the cops are the bad guys and women it's
your fault
and now you got to go up to law abiding
citizens and tell them they can't earn a
living
i mean they couldn't the timing couldn't
be worse let alone the mission
well that's that's part of the issue
when you look at this year for law
enforcement after minneapolis
and the california legislature made its
mission to defund the police to change
the rules
to come out with new legislation that
restrict the way we can do our job
so on one hand you're saying we want you
to stop doing things that would result
in actions against the community and on
the other hand we're saying
but not this time the rules are
different go out and arrest people and
i'm not sure that we ever want to be in
a position where
law enforcement operating with that uh
with that mission in mind to go out and
arrest lawful residents of the county
who are just trying to make ends meet
and are doing so by following the rules
yeah the rules can't change week by week
and i think it's been very difficult for
our constituents in orange county
throughout the state and the nation
quite honestly
right to keep redefining the way we
operate sheriff i
you know know that about you great
courage and standing up hopefully no
retribution
from sacramento if there is please come
back you're doing the right thing
sheriff thank you and have a great
holiday thank you so much
all right we reached out to governor
newsome for a statement but he was at
the french laundry eating dinner